thank you
[Music]
we're back we're here welcome everybody
this is a little touch and go we're here
Justice here
all the conservatives in the world
they should fear us ladies and gentlemen
we are all domestic terrorists you just
don't know what to expect yeah
conserve conservatives should fear my
wrath I played basketball last night
full court pickup basketball for like
two hours and I think like half of my
body is paralyzed now yeah that's the
kind of energy I'm bringing to the table
baby what
um depends depends on the circumstances
which means no like I there was a time
and place in my life where I could dunk
fairly consistently never in a game on a
fast break I don't think I've never like
done that but I could don't don't take
this the wrong way but you don't look
like someone with mad hops as they say
no that's not you're not wrong I'm I'm
very heavy yeah you're hit you got yeah
weight except Bradley Martin can dunk
and we are around the same we're around
this like I'll just tell you like this
we're around the same weight and around
the same height but that [__] dunk
that's because he deadlifts 700 pounds I
deadlift 400 pounds there's a 300 pound
difference between our our pushing power
I think I I I wouldn't feel too bad
about that I think he spends a little
more time working out probably than yeah
he's got he's got a little bit more help
than I do as well for a longer period of
time but you know obviously that doesn't
discount the tremendous amount of hard
work he puts of course not no Heavens no
well welcome today guys we got all kinds
of fun stuff to talk about Jordan
Peterson's a steak cooking advice we're
going to talk about the Mr Beast
controversy he's actually been uh outed
as a communist and Hassan has a hit on
him now from uh yeah well I have to eat
him now because like he's like a bigger
communist you know that's how it works
you either have to fight like yeah you
have to no no no no no no no no we the
left is moved past eating the ridge it's
just eat the richest means like let's
let's yell at each other let's that's
always you you know you know they're
coming for you bro when they get hungry
dude I don't give a [__] they hate my
dick how about that uh let's see we got
all kinds of good stuff Crowders by
sexual phase uh is is
you know comes out we also have yay can
I just ask why what's going on with this
number one bullet point here what are
you guys gonna make fun of me no I'm a
huge one piece fan oh okay I wanted to
ask you about it because uh you've been
you tweeted about there's a there's
there's a reaction I think one of my one
of my stains actually posted it's kind
of like
a little bit I mean it's like not that
big of a spoiler I think yeah dude I
have so many big spoilers that I want to
talk about you know Oda is like a
leftist like straight up yeah a snake
you mean oh the guy oh no no no no no
odor the guy who made yeah go to I
didn't know that but yes I saw you
Tweeting Luffy's dad is a is the head of
the Revolutionary Army bro so same snake
no dragon all right Dragon but but no
that is his name is I think
um
like so Oda has a chig of our poster in
his room uh that they uh
uh that they've like people in the
fandom have post uh pointed to
but um pretty sure yeah Luffy's dad is
is tailored off of uh Che Guevara or
potentially Fido Castro
Fidel Castro now there's a now there's
someone to look up to
I mean he he yeah if I mean if you're
leftist like yeah you're
you know people people people like Fidel
[__] yeah you kidding me okay absolutely
Che Guevara as well look these guys are
not infallible they've done a lot of
[__] you know not so great things but
you always gotta you always gotta
compare it to what I thought everybody
hated Astro for some reason or yeah well
of course you hate you I don't hate him
I don't know much no no I'm saying of
course you think that yeah Living in
America of course everybody hates but
what isn't there a bunch of like uh of
people who left and lived here all hate
Castro yes is that because like they're
rich [__] who had to flee some are and
some aren't as is the case with any kind
of Revolution or any kind of like uh
political uh instability
there are a lot of people who left that
you know owned the sugar plantations and
then there are a lot of people who left
that did not that still felt uh you know
that the new regime was brutal and
oppressive regardless there are people
who felt like they were betrayed and
there are people who look for Economic
Opportunity in the United States of
America but yes
for the the uh as far as I understand
you know uh yes Cubans in America are
not fans of fetal cats okay
understandable well anyway rest in peace
going Mary
gone but not forgotten yeah
have you gotten to the part where they
get the new boat yet no no I haven't
that's fire
the point always is you gotta you gotta
look at like not just Fidel Castro or
Che Guevara but you got to look at who
they they came after like who who they
they dethroned and Batista was a far
more brutal individual than than Fidel
Castro was who's your favorite one-piece
character oh easy Zorro yeah zoro's sick
yeah he's so cool yeah he's the coolest
I think he's he's dope
um
I think I actually you know what maybe
Nico Robin Nico Robin is pretty fire I
like the vibe I love her yeah she's
stacked she's best bro okay is this
every girl is stacked in one piece
that's just he's a pervert just like
well you know what in the in the
beginning of the show I was kind of
happily surprised by how not perverted
the female characters were bro nami's
titties grew like yeah [__] cups
every season yeah exactly like she
looked normal I was like okay maybe this
is an anime that isn't written by a
perverted freak and then now when I'm on
the season I'm on like uh dude it's like
it's like ridiculous okay here's the
thing here's what I'll say about this
here's what I'll say about this they're
all the way up to her at it's like dude
you know how I just said you know you
gotta you gotta measure fito Castro's
accomplishments or who he is by looking
at who he came uh after it's the same
with anime you gotta measure how
perverted an anime is by looking at how
perverted anime is in general and with
respect to like all the fan services
[__] out there I think uh one formative
accomplishment for Oda is that a lot of
the female characters thus far in the
story have insanely good backstories
like they almost they even task they
even pass like Bechtel test which is
unimaginable for for you know what I
mean wait what is for anyone where two
women have a have a conversation between
each other I don't even know if it
passes bectal test probably not but it's
[__] anime but wait check this out
here's a here's the shot this is from I
guess meme piece that I just got to this
episode and oh I just saw dude I just
wait sorry it's literally bro you did
not just get to this episode
you've been a fan of one piece this this
is uh maybe I was confused this is
Annie's Lobby okay I I actually paused
this Frame to show my brother how much
of a pervert uh I thought this was from
a later uh no no who's Danny's Lobby I
just watched this okay yeah I see
and then and then it's just like a tit
shot
wait what no it's coming up there it is
but that's the honestly like every frame
is like every frame of paintings yes
you're right
that's still pain I guess yeah I agree
anime that is still very tame anime is
very fan service-y but like I said I
mean here look at this this is what she
looks like in the show I think this is a
people are so weird about this [__] I'm
getting into all kinds of weird [__]
stuff here brother
the animators is that not Oda okay
everybody calm down there's
this is what she looked like you could
see her like vagina curves bruh middle
like how low is she wearing those pants
okay she looks great
um look at I don't know how low is she
wearing those pants dude her vagina is
like right below the damn place and it's
not real obviously but I'm just I know
it's not real a bunch of [__] horny
hikomoris who don't like leave their
house and think that like makes me a
little uncomfortable because I'm you
know 37 and I'm sitting at home watching
the show which I love it is like the
most famous anime it's very cozy I like
it because it's cozy that's it
this makes me uncomfortable though
because if so I don't know how to
explain this to somebody who's outside
exploding Milk porn Road never explain
anime to someone who is outside just
don't do that I've never I need to watch
it in private like if people if people
in the if people in the real world ask
me if I like anime I say ew no what the
[__] I'm not a pervert I just say yeah
what is what is the anime yeah what no
I'm not a kid what what am I a child no
I don't watch animated stuff
coming well there it is I love one piece
uh it's awesome it's it's I love people
complain that it's so long and I'll be
frank because there's like a thousand
hundred episodes
at first I was like there's no way I'm
gonna watch this but actually you know
when you get a good show
and then you run out of episodes how
tragic that is you never run out of
episodes yeah that's true there's a
thousand there's literally a thousand
episodes a thousand hundred I am in
334 or something like this
and and you know there's no
it's it's seemingly Gonna Keep Going On
which is great it's based off of a of a
comic right yeah yeah
either oh that hasn't ended no it's
still going isn't that nuts wow but you
know what I do like about one piece to
make why don't we just Tuttle this the
one Piece episode sure I do feel like
the plot is always moving forward I
don't feel like they're wasting time you
know what I mean that's true I think the
earlier Seasons they definitely wasted
more time however
when you get to like where I'm at you're
like oh my God this is this was all
relevant like even shitty like even
shitty lame characters from like
literally the first episode oh yeah
you'll see them yeah Seven Seasons later
and you're like what the [__] that's
yeah that's crazy that they like there's
no frame goes uh to waste nothing real
with you has fun it really picks up
around episode 470. I'm actually not
kidding that sounds like such a [__]
meme but it's I believe it well I mean
listen Water Seven has been water seven
in any Lobby have been one of my faves
two favorite arcs so far so yeah like
really good got Nico Robin is so sick
all right calm down bro I wish she was
real Nico Robin best girl bro I'm sure I
can get you a Nico Robin uh
all right let's talk about something
else uh thank you one piece though we
love you do you want to see the video of
me almost crying when I watch The Tick
Tock of uh going Mary yeah actually no
no let's not do that let's just move on
the going Mary oh she was such a good
ship yeah
but wait till you meet the the okay okay
okay
oh yeah the new one is
foreign
this is why this is like so much ammo
for random like conservatives to clip
out and be like look at these two
[__] adult man children like getting
on for everybody and and greased up over
[__] anime yeah at least Temple has a
sword on his wall what the [__] does he
have to say Crowder has a holster and by
the way at least I don't watch Carl tuck
Tucker Carl [__] yeah no they they like
I don't know they fantasize about like
the founding fathers you know what I
mean I'd rather watch anime than like
glaze up a bunch of slavers you know and
fantasize about being like a bunch of
slavers who would die at the age of 35
because they had to cut their [__]
limbs off 100 brother
uh my Tucka yeah so anyway
let's talk about a little bit on Jordan
Peterson he's actually as you guys know
deep into the all meat diet huge fan of
uh
he's actually I'm gonna issue a trigger
warning here not for the vegans but
actually for the meat eaters I you know
I eat a lot I'm actually cutting back on
my red meat you you'll be happy to know
but I am proud of you thank you but I
have put a lot of effort and time into
how to cook steaks now this man here
look at this Ethan this man here bought
a Japanese A5 wagyu and he says how
would you guys cook this beauty now this
does it have a price on it this thing
probably costs like 500 bucks maybe more
um
probably like 200 I think
quit speaking you
shut up Hassan that's what Jordan just
said uh he says this man literally told
this [__] guy
he says
freeze it
and then air fry it at 450.
drain the fat
and then add water bro I I did dude I
did I did literally like an hour on this
on my show when I first when it first
came out I'm not even kidding this is
actually like old when I saw this tweet
I was like he should go to jail
I I'm not you know how like oh she's 16
if you misgender a trans person you go
to jail like that's not real but I wish
it was specifically for this okay you
know you should go to jail for this we
should actually try this maybe no I
can't do that no I can't allow that that
is what I mean this okay A5 wagyu maybe
specifically for those of you who don't
know if you want to pull that back up
okay there I'm in trouble again it is
the highest quality of meat that you can
get on this planet okay if I wagyu A5 is
the is the designation the specificity
the reason why it's so uh the reason why
it's regarded as a delicacy is because
of the unique marbling okay in order to
get that marbling we're talking about
hundreds of years of like cow technology
these cows get fed they're not allowed
to move they're massaged regularly and
they listen to [__] like classical
music and [__] okay like the way to get
this marbling which is the fat inside of
the protein okay
that is a scientific process they're the
only ones to do it really yeah it's a
small place in Japan yes so whenever
people say like oh this is Kobe beef or
whatever like half the time that's not
real A5 wagyu this is okay
you can see it so the fat is literally
what actually makes the steak what it is
so Jordan Peterson saying drain the fat
Add Water I literally I just like I hope
he is never allowed to enter Japan or
the United States of America ever again
this man said steam it he goes out of
water and steam that [__]
yeah but somebody actually took his
advice
um [__] you I don't know if you don't
like it oh wait where's that photo oh
wait where's that photo of someone who
took his advice and sent a picture
yeah someone took his advice it was so
good
yeah I shame on you Mr Peterson you
that's you vile freak how dare you God
he tweeted so much what this guy dude
this is just one hour of scrolling yeah
here's Hassan you see this someone said
Hey Big Image from uh that's like a I
know
sorry I say that I've had some posts I'm
so serious I get like I get very
I get very serious about meat and what's
happening back there what
happened to the picture you took it down
so fast
yeah I cooked my Wagyu steak exactly how
he recommended Frozen then air fried
turned out delicious I just oh God I
can't I can't look at it and then he
actually responded to that I don't think
he knew it was a joke but yeah shame on
you Jordan Peterson uh I want to point
some out here okay
first of all constantly eating red meat
not goofy carnivore diet not healthy for
you no okay understand this it's not I
eat so much chicken I love red meat I
eat red meat too regularly okay but what
you need to understand if you only have
red meat you're gonna have health
complications apple cider is gonna
probably take you out like it almost
killed Jordan Peterson but the most
offensive part of this entire process is
that if you are advocating to eat
[__] a carnivore diet you know what I
mean at least develop an appreciation
for the meat that you're consuming the
animal that you have butchered and
murdered okay let let it not die in vain
by doing that you are disrespecting the
[__] animal what are you saying bro
this is perfectly cooked so on top of
that like how how do you make a diet
like how do you claim that you have this
like incredible diet okay this carnivore
diet which requires you to eat meat and
you still don't know how to cook meat
think again and sunshine
um Morgan Peterson does nothing wrong
and you are a hater also you're a
communist YOLO [__] get some actually
so the whole all-meat diet is actually a
total [__] Griff that his daughter a
friend of Andrew Tate is doing she
actually even gave a a speech here
explaining that Force feeding your
infant meat will make their head bigger
now I'm not sure that's a good thing
I was so confused by this I'm not sure
about making you know what I mean well I
mean this is a Kayla Peterson maybe you
should give it I [__] wish my parents
gave it a shot maybe horse feeding you
meat yeah yeah they kind of they kind of
[__] up on that one didn't they maybe
sad we need you anyway have you seen
this clip it's great food that people
can actually survive on as a single food
without supplementing anything else
which is the perfect Elemental diet for
a sick person if you use meat as a first
food for a baby their head circumference
is actually larger than babies fed
without meat yeah I think that's called
a birth defect
it may be once I think that's called
they're like Yo dude if you force feed
your child meat instead of milk their
head ends up 200 larger are we missing
something does she think does she think
bigger head means bigger brain they can
mean big brain babies yeah like that's
why Sebastian Gorka is the smartest
American
smartest Hungarian and American
the ketogenic diet which is the type of
diet I'm on minus the plant food has
been shot yo I'm on keto minus the
veggies veggies are for gay people
clearly
she's so [__] nuts
yeah I just I also don't believe it like
I I low-key don't believe that she's
just exclusively eating me in the way
that she presents it because like you
you truly would have way more Health
complications like I just
there's no way I agree with you I think
she's lying but she has this thing
called The Lion Club where people pay
her monthly for advice it's really weird
and this is the kind of advice force
feed your new your infant through a
syringe ground up [__] cow blood or
some [__] epilepsy since the 1920s and
was kind of put out of fashion by
anti-epileptics and the first study on
the carnivore diet the big
anti-epileptic Lobby damn
they got us again released by Harvard
this November adults consuming a
carnivore diet experienced few adverse
effects and instead reported health
benefits and high satisfaction the
surprise came because an average of 90
percent of people saw improvements
across all diseases on the diet
one in four people if you stop and think
what she's actually advocating for it's
she wants people to eat only meat like
do you understand like how
[__] up that is for like the world
it's bad for the environment it's so bad
it's also like not something that people
can do because it's like super expensive
it's super expensive and we will
absolutely debit well that's why Jordan
Peterson's always going on and on now
about how global warming is a hoax like
the man this is going on about the
global warming is a hoax because he's an
oil lobbyist like make no mistake he's
getting money one million percent I'd
bet money that he's getting paid by the
oil Lobby I mean he is actually white
well he's on the daily wire now yeah
it's not even just that but also like he
does the speaking engagements and stuff
where he's constantly talking about like
well logging is destroying the
environment too I mean
there's nothing wrong with fossil fuels
that's how we uplift the third world
like that sort of [__] God the oil Lobby
is so [__] devious anyway rats will
dance for money he does get speaking
engagement fees from them oh [__] uh
one in four people over 64 have type 2
diabetes in America all respondents with
diabetes discontinued non-insulin
injection agents this this she really
said no more insulin just eat meat
yo you got diabetes
throw that in fill it out
for air fry steak
okay for those of you who like will try
and make an argument or something about
this like here's the thing yes like a a
bariatric surgery a gastric bypass will
cure your diabetes unless you're type
one right
um
or wait is it type two the one that's
like I think it's permanent and a
genetic two is the permanent one yeah
okay unless you type two but make no
mistake
you wouldn't be you wouldn't be uh
fixing curing your diabetes by just
eating meat you'd be curing your
diabetes if you actually end up losing
weight that's like of course you're
going to lose weight with all meat
because like
you're gonna get ill if you eat like
what 2 000 calories of meat every day
you'll be like absolutely
I gotta write type one is permanent type
two is okay thank you for that
yeah
she's so vile 84 discontinued oral
medication and 92 percent of
participants on the carnivore diet with
type 2 diabetes discontinued insulin
altogether over 2 000 people were
studied who were on the diet for over
six months and there was a 90 reduction
in all diseases
the demonization of red meat was based
off of a few hypothesis the demonization
of red meat who the [__] demonizing
already talking red meat owls of [__]
like you know systematic Slaughter you
want to know what how farts are
literally causing Global you want to
know who's demonizing red meat her
[__] dad bro yeah I saw what I saw
what he did with the I don't know what
he suggested with with that A5 wagyu is
so
is so disgusting
is oh God it's actually hateful if I
could call I would like to call it a
hate crime it is a hate crime it's a
hate crime against Japanese cows but
like it's it's so insane what she's
advocating for like if even if what
she's saying is true let's assume that
eating cows cures every [__] uh
sickness in the world it's crazy but how
you gonna do that how are you gonna get
enough cows even for the United States
to feed everybody just cow meat every
meal like what world are you even
wanting to build with that
it's crazy
because the uh the study when I saw this
video I was like she's talking about a
Harvard study and I was like I gotta see
what this is like if there's any
validity to it yeah okay and I know what
you're I know what your purpose was you
you have a bias I have an agenda here
it's true it's true but yeah I found the
study and the study itself makes a lot
of points about that how
um it is in no way realistic for you
know the entire population to switch to
this kind of diet because of those
environmental concerns it'd be
catastrophic yeah they they point that
out and on top of that this study was
all self-reported by
people that are super into the carnivore
diet so of course they're saying oh yeah
it's great because I mean you know how
these people are they're all like her
they they think it's like a cure-all
they self-reported so how did they find
the participants on like Twitter on
social media but what's the point of
even making this like Harvard's falling
apart what's the point of even doing
this I mean like hey corner of our diet
people tell me how you those are two
it's because they're too focused on
doing pronoun studies so they the the
institution of Harvard is falling apart
folks that's right they're not even
doing good studies no more I tell you
what man I mean like you can do a
self-world of study it's just like
there's no way to recreate this I don't
think and also
diets are so complicated so complex
because human beings are so different
from one another
um there's different ways that people
process metabolize food it's just stupid
it's just stupid to be like oh just the
carnivore diet will will work when
ultimately yes if you dramatically shift
your diet
and one thing I always say is you have
to make sure your diet is your diet is
whatever it is right like you could have
unhealthy diet you can have a healthy
diet but you have to make sure that your
diet is one that you can follow for the
rest of your life uh otherwise you will
yo-yo your weight will go back and forth
as soon as you're I guess quote-unquote
diet is over right because there's no
such thing and
I don't think you can do that with just
straight meat well the reason people do
lose weight on meat is because
going to like one food is is like uh it
is it's a technique in in nutrition and
in health to figure out like if you're
having food allergies or certain foods
aren't doing good for your body so if
you if you are having some kind of
allergies and you feel sick from eating
which I assume these people probably do
to do something as radical as that if
you go back down to just eating meat
then you know whatever you were eating
before is out of your diet but you're
not you're supposed to slowly add things
back in one at a time not just go oh I'm
just going to eat meat forever that
doesn't make any [__] sense to go
back you're literally describing fixing
Eating Disorders like that's what
dietitians would just would teach you on
step by step yeah they they just they
just they like sticking in the
dysfunction part yeah well I I it's just
there's it's no fun the [__] like yeah
food is fuel but you can make healthier
choices that work for you I do it you
know I I've been relatively successful
in this endeavor it just pisses me off
that they they take something that I
enjoy eating and then they turn it into
like this awful thing
like they're they're they advocate for
like the worst kind of uh the worst type
of consumption they're still you can
still have carbs you should have a
healthy balanced diet it's so stupid uh
going back to the survey it says
or this is the study she's citing so not
only were they uh
self-assessed but it does not include
any objective assessment of their diet
nutrition status health related outcomes
or health Associated behaviors oh why
does it lie yeah I know
so like they said further investigation
is needed to better understand the diet
and its impact on health and that's
directly from the study so it's not even
that it's like a bad study like they
acknowledge the shortcomings in the
study it's just they were super
preliminary right exactly and she's
we're not talking about this
apparently uh I just saw somebody in the
chat mention it Oxford yeah it looks
like some British chick is like the kids
in the back look like a bit composers a
bit dressed up isn't it yeah
big fan
Baseball standing attention to your her
Royal Highness Michaela
the lion diet
Peterson I love it
[Music]
studies that have been proven to be
false saturated fat has slowly been
disappearing as the cause of heart
disease in scientific literature yeah to
relax you know what I mean be
comfortable up there like she's ready to
run I've heard londonistan is crime
infested lost a knife crime here in it
no to keep your bag on you keep the
fanny
foreign
because it's not the cause for heart
disease okay the studies on colorectal
cancer were done on people who also ate
more sugar and processed foods
McDonald's thank you for the b-roll of
Chinese food when you don't consume
plants
our populations need
high levels of vitamins it turns out
that's only necessary because we're
consuming so many carbs okay
I don't disagree with this it's just so
[__] annoying when like people are
talking when people want to like sell
their fad diets they genuinely are it
just frustrates me so much because they
always sneak in normal factually
accurate information in there not the
fiber part but like yes the American
diet is absolutely [__] okay we uh we
have a tremendous amount of we have a
tremendous amount of carbs carbs are not
as carbs are not as filling overall no
but she's talking about usually
processed sugars they have like psycho
takes on carbs they're like no [__]
carbs ever yeah I'm not I'm not a keto
Advocate I've done keto and it's not
it's not sustainable I don't like it
it's not for me maybe it is for you who
knows but what I was trying to say is
like yes if you you have a diet that
comprises almost exclusively of [__]
carbs and like very little protein yes
your muscles are going to atrophy you're
not getting enough you're not getting
enough nutrients you're not getting
enough macronutrients who's doing that
you're living on just like french fries
I mean I mean they're people have [__]
died but I'm saying like of course
that's bad for you nothing but bread
bread yeah that's yeah that's not a good
diet it's also cheaper remember it's
worse eating just bread or just red meat
probably just bread yeah no eating just
bread is worse then she's onto something
but but that's but you're right like
that's an insane one-to-one comparison
right like no one is eating just bread
or just rice or whatever somebody's just
eating carbs they know they're unhealthy
you know what I mean like that's not a
[__] mystery but for some reason
she's convinced that eating just meat to
the Dome
is the greatest thing that ever happened
something that you guys just should
always keep in mind is that all fad
diets
basically are operating sneakily under
the same fundamentals okay
calories and calories out is real it's
just you know your body is a machine
obviously it varies uh from person to
person so people have a higher more
Active Metabolism they're less sedentary
they're more fidgety even you know what
I mean there's like multiple different
ways that your body is constantly
Burning uh and and needs more carbs or
needs more calories sorry
these guys all are just basically taking
that fundamental principle and then
adding unnecessary weird [__] to to you
know
uh deviate from the rest and and make
themselves seem like a like a more
marketable well trendy Dieter I find a
lot of of those diets they just act they
kind of accidentally you just consume
less because the diet is so [__]
crazy like keto it's like
um if you're not if you're cutting off
processed food and carbs and sugar
you're probably going to lose weight
regardless of what you're eating but
here's Jordan Peterson talking very
highly about his all-made diet I've been
eating I've been eating I've been eating
his voice is so [__] crazy I've been
eating only red meat basically nothing
but meat I don't like to talk about this
much because I'm not a dietitian and
it's really weird in some ways I just
hate this diet because I love right
really because your daughter's selling a
whole [__] course about it love to
cook you can change bro I love to go out
to restaurants it's very restrictive but
um I when I went on this diet to begin
with because of autoimmune issues as far
as I could tell yeah I lost like 50
pounds in six months it was ridiculous
like I wasn't
really that much overweight I'm about
six two so but it like eight pounds a
month
this is fast forward a month or
something of him yeah I see here's
Jordan Peterson on his are you still
eating your all beef diet
unfortunately yes
really just just beef no can you have
like ketchup on it nothing it isn't
something I would lightly recommend it's
a little hard on your social life such a
badass dude and it's dull as hell but
but what's it what has it done for you
well I lost 50 pounds in seven months he
looks so happy by the way with his dude
I think the meat is working with the
sigma when you put the sigma grind fit
music behind it like this this effect
liberal man who is like very clearly
breaking his [__] body mind and soul
who got like you know who almost died
from a [__] apple cider attack whose
daughter May or not may not be trying to
kill him actively okay
um who had to go into a medically
induced coma at a certain point in his
[__] life and uh you know that guy
all of a sudden he looks cool you know
no it's normal to be like this this
[__] lifeless husk it was like yes
I'm crying all the time because I have a
hormonal imbalance but honestly it's
okay
because I've lost a lot of weight I've
lost weight the kids are saying w r is
I'm off all my psychiatric drugs he says
that too can't you tell I'm doing
wonderful Dude this man looks like he's
on the [__] edge of ending it all
stop snoring I stopped storing I had
some autoimmune conditions that seem to
have gone away that is so stupid I'm not
taking antidepressants my mood isn't
perfectly regulated but dude that's an
understatement you look like you're
gonna kill yourself after this so you
[__] no didn't take brother like I
don't have to take any meds I don't wipe
anymore I've had over 40 pizzas in the
last 30 days I don't even look to see if
it's dirty I just assume it is
I'm under a fair bit of stress so that
might have something to do with it I
sleep much less that's not good more I I
now that I don't think I sleep two hours
a day bro bro bro especially the Sleep
part like it's it's so important oh my
God for for a healthy body mind soul
whatever the [__] you want to call it
your sleep is so so incredibly important
you need to get like it's not a meme
that people say like you need to get
eight hours like I and I say this to
someone who doesn't get eight hours but
I'm telling you like it's it's bananas
he's like yeah I can work out I can work
more now that I don't sleep yeah I used
to say that when I slept [__] four
hours nah yeah it just ruined me I'm off
my antidepressants and I'm off sleep as
well
it turns out sleep is a conspiracy my
big pillow yeah sleep is so sleep is
definitely hugely important in your
weight loss weight gain whatever your
dietary whatever your goals are sleep is
genuinely important because it you know
your body's not going to process
hormones uh correctly your body's not
going to push out the the right kind of
hormones that you need now let's talk
about Mr Beast let's try to hit our all
of our main topics here
so I think everybody had kind of a
visceral reaction to this thumbnail
first of all without even analyzing the
content of the video I think we can all
just look at this and appreciate how
[__] dystopian and weird it is like
this man the smile first of all
is this a new thing I mean if Mr Beast
is doing it must be like there must be a
reason for it
but yeah it is kind of it's so creepy
and then this kid who's like obviously
like fake Photoshop tears but it's
almost like look what I did for this
[__] little [__] I don't know he's
like he thinks he's like a Willy Wonka
the combo universally is like seen as
like a weird one but I think that's like
the new meta I guess on YouTube this is
like a dharmon-ass thumbo yeah well you
know Mr B yeah like you said if Mr Beast
is doing it then you know that's what it
is
right now what video has 76 million
views so something's working yeah so
yeah immediately and I saw some people
talking about like this this thumbnail's
demonic yeah it was all overruled who
said that there's something entirely
demonic about this thing and he left it
at that and he just showed like the
thumbnail
and people were like you're saying it's
demonic to cure a thousand people's
blindness like [__] you and the dude
that they're dunking on is like a
[__] public defender like dude what
do you mean he's like his entire life is
[__] charity you [__] shut the
[__] up like he's literally people he
literally defends poor people in the
criminal justice system like shut the
[__] up
um people get very defensive of Mr Beast
you know and
I get it there's people that try to take
shots at him some journalists and stuff
over silly [__] and he is he is you know
a good guy that does good things and
people [__] just love him right yeah
but at the same time I'm not criticizing
the what he I think he did a great thing
I think he did a great thing yeah and I
think the people who are criticizing it
you and others the criticism is that the
fact that we live in a country
where so many [__] people are
desperate for an entirely curable 10
minute surgery dude it's a terrible
blindness like they cannot see and you
can cure it in 10 minutes yeah it's just
like little suck and and it's like so
third world of us well I mean but so
even Mr B's like who is still very much
a big fan of capitalism can you please
can you switch to this uh he's a big fan
of capitalism Jimmy uh and and even he
recognizes despite being a big fan of
capitalism that this is like weird
because he he literally in the video
says
it doesn't really make sense because
like these guys could just go back to
work after their blindness is cured you
know what I mean and it's like yeah that
is again he has arrived at the heart of
the problem which is that it doesn't
even make sense from a pro-capitalism
perspective because you would have a
more efficient labor force that you can
you know that you can work harder if you
want from the from the point of capital
owners that's precisely the reason why
most developed Nations if not all of
them have some form of either affordable
or free health care for this [__]
reason so the actually except for
America and for pieces of [__] I think
Mr Beast is actually getting a little
bit radicalized from this which is great
right because I don't think but listen
to this tweet he says I don't understand
why curable blindness is a thing why
don't government step in and help even
if you're thinking purely from a
financial standpoint it's hard to see
how they don't Roi on taxes from people
being able to work again that he's 100
right and the reason is because
um
we hate poor people we hate no the
reason is because we can make more money
we can make more money off of this money
that's the whole point it's like we are
so desperately looking at any Avenue we
can to just squeeze out like the
remainder profits that we can and
America is like accelerated on the
capitalism uh on the on the stages of
capitalism I guess than other countries
in the sense that like it's it's
conducting self-harm to its labor force
to its citizens specifically so it can
make more money in the stock market and
in general drive more profits because
it's profitable especially because
Americans hate poor people
they don't want to help other people
they think that they should help
themselves
well Steinbeck Steinbeck is is has the
wonderful quote on this socialism will
never work I mean I guess it's
paraphrase I'm paraphrasing it and it's
attributed to Steinbeck but he says
socialism will never work in America
because the working class do not see
themselves as a the exploited
proletariat but instead temporarily
embarrassed millionaires I think that
was Mark Twain
it's attributed to Steinbeck but I don't
think it's it's I don't think it's
either of them I'm looking it up right
now but but yeah but it makes sense if
it is Steinbeck right because we have
this rugged individualism and people
especially poor people who are like I'm
barely Rich enough to afford that then
they go I'm not I don't want none of my
taxes going they get obsessed with like
this is my money fixing these God damn
homeless degenerates money
they're like I cannot see I cannot work
go flip a burger you degenerate I cannot
see well that's your problem maybe your
mama shouldn't [__] their cousin see
y'all Partners it's just it is it is
unimaginably cruel and it's very
frustrating anytime I [__] see like
the feel-good stories that they run in
the media specifically to be like see we
have the we have the power to take you
know matters into our own hands and save
ourselves and it's like bro everywhere
else like in [__] Brazil people
aren't thinking about this in the same
way yeah so in his video something has
stood out to me is he lists all these
other countries that he's going to to
help people yeah with uh preventable
blindness so it's like America
and then the other [__] was like uh he's
just all African nations yeah like all
developing countries it's America and
then developing nations because America
is a third world country with a Gucci
belt straight up Jimmy here let's see
yeah
Western imperialism Mexico once
surprised me a little bit but I guess we
looked into that because Mexico does
have Universal I guess it's just a
really long wait to get it done
Honduras
Indonesia Brazil Vietnam in
Vietnam it's like also Jamaica and and
where we had the biggest impact of all
America yeah
it's crazy though like as far as as far
as looking at those dead and curable
blindness baseball
terrible blindness
just 10 minutes with the needle and you
can't see once again
[Applause]
[Music]
that's America
all right number one in police brutality
per capita number one in like uh the The
Prisoner population on the planet in
totality but also uh per capita you know
number one in medical debt
it's just we're we are number one baby
in like all the [__] worst ways that
you could think
um it was Steinbeck actually no it is it
is misattributed to Steinbeck regularly
I'm pretty sure it's not actually what
I'm seeing is that the the the version
uh temporarily embarrassed millionaires
is is not like that's a later Corruption
of the actual quote which is that
everyone is a temporarily embarrassed
capitalist and that is Steinbeck he did
say that
yeah but anyway yeah so I think the
video
you know it exposes something really
[__] up about our country and that's
why I think people were having a
reaction not to Jimmy who obviously is
doing a good thing he's putting his
money out there to help people and
that's awesome
but uh
we I don't nobody wants to see how much
we're actually failing the people of
this country I think the funnier part
about that quote that I have to also
mention the original quote is uh from a
short history in progress by Ronald
Wright
um and something that he has like
Steinbeck has talked about regularly
about Communists is that he says I guess
the trouble was that we didn't have any
self-admitted proletarians people who
are you know proud of being working
class everyone was a temporarily
embarrassed capitalist maybe the
Communist so closely questioned by the
investigation committees were a danger
to America but the ones I knew at least
they admitted to be Communists couldn't
have couldn't have disrupted a Sunday
school picnic besides they were too busy
fighting amongst themselves some things
never change
yeah you know what
um the average price for this surgery in
the United States is seven thousand
dollars it takes 15 minutes to perform
that's a lot of money for a 15 operation
a 15-minute operation yeah
but if it's just putting a little vacuum
[__] I'll do it you know I mean just
train like we don't why do we need
doctors just train someone with a little
vacuum and put get it in there and suck
that [__] out bro dude I'm not even
joking wait are you no dude of course
not what no but if it's just literally
like the libertarian solution absolutely
listen to what I'm saying bro
if it's just if you just need them to do
this one procedure
you can learn how to do it and do it
super cheap for a ton of people bro the
problem is not that like qualifications
are too high to do medical procedures no
but this one we gotta we gotta let's get
people in there and start sucking bro
sucks
what's funny about that is like when
something goes sideways you start like
gushing blood out of an eyeball artery
he's like I don't know what to do yeah I
don't know if I'm letting you but if you
can't see
then like what do you have to lose to go
to [__] dude that's crazy no dude
you're literally this eyeball suckered
chop okay you are unironically making
like the Milton Friedman argument right
now I'm not this is like this is like
the hyper libertarian solution dude I'm
not saying open heart surgery should be
done by like your neighbor all right
I'm saying the eyeball [__] I'm saying
let's get some let's get some suckers I
am not in agreement there no here's the
real solution you you are wrong what you
should do is not demerulate medicine but
instead make it free to educate people
so we have more [__] doctors it's
super my ways cheaper and also have a
public health care structure and
nationalized Healthcare structure where
doctors have to do a couple years in
rural hospitals so we can finally have
better medicine in rural areas because
currently as it stands even though
Healthcare is not considered well
Hospital Administration is not
considered profitable and therefore
there aren't enough you know rural
hospitals it's not profitable anywhere
it's already it's already being operated
by like you know wealthy donors and and
uh and government spending
make it so that doctors have to go and
work I have an idea how about this
there's a clinic Ethan's eyeball sucker
and then you have a hold on hear me out
so you have eight rooms with trained
trained folks with the eyeball sucker
and then you have one doctor there so if
something goes wrong they could if the
eyeball starts to die or their blood did
they have go into Red Alert Bloom code
the doctor comes in and can help out
hold on that sounds
horrific yeah but you know what's
horrific not seeing when you can see now
I I understand why you have this opinion
but I can see a million ways that this
goes wrong and you're basically saying
listen like
you know poor people who can't get their
[__] fixed like yeah they're gonna get
some lower Quality Health Care but you
know it's a good thing no that's an
awful
like it
yes Ethan that's crazy it's better than
nothing dude no you need to you need
like if everyone gets quality held up
here obviously that's not the ideal
solution right obviously it's it's not a
good solution at all not the ideal it's
one shared by many Libertarians too I'm
just listen I don't care about what
Libertarians care about okay [__] they
can all go die in a fire I don't care
this is me I am metaphorically I'm well
what am I I don't have a fire I'm not
throwing anyone to a fire right you
don't have a fight I can wish death he
doesn't have access to fight I can I can
you can't anything let's see let's move
I'm not gonna let's get off the death
yeah yeah so
I'm not saying it's the ideal solution
but it is a solution yes I mean exactly
acknowledge that it is a solution
illusion they're about him just but it's
not a good solution Ethan it's a bad one
because it it's one that would lead to
many many complications down the line
long-term consequences it's literally
you don't know that why are you saying
that why do we need you abortion know
that why do we need abortion clinics
why do we need abortion facilities
people could technically do back alley
abortions what happens when people do
back alley abortions by like oh this
isn't back out random untrained people
who are like trying to offer them help
with like you know uh uh I'm not saying
back alley [__] cataract surgery I'm
saying Ethan's eyeball sucking I feel
like highly explained cataract surgery
is a little bit more complicated than
taking an abortion pill which you can
now at this point do at home uh when the
moment that we talk about surgery even
if it's just a little suck I think that
that is still a very complicated process
and it should be handled by medical
professionals not just people who are
like you know learning about
eyeball suck listen we just did a poll
32 percent says they would let me suck
their eyeball
and they're not even blind probably 66
says no it's so but still 30 it's not
looking good Ethan no but you're you're
missing the the plot you're missing the
the real point is 30 said yes
that's a business behind what you're
advocating for is exactly why Milton
Friedman uh would advocate for the Fort
Pinto to continue bro I'm not
co-founding Milton I don't even know
about anybody named Milton I know but
the principle is the same because like
you're basically saying individuals as
consumers have the responsibility to
make rational choices in the market and
therefore government regulation should
be abolished in this field or at least
like deregulated because ultimately if
you die and you get a Ford Pinto if your
[__] car explodes when you're in the
process of driving it it's not up to
Ford and it's not up to the government
to make sure that there are standards
that they need to abide by it's up to
the individual consumer that made the
choice and if they're poor they made the
wrong Always by getting a pinto but at
least they got a car for the process
before they exploded on them well I
don't even know what you're talking
about I just want to suck people's
eyeballs okay
I think I found a video listen I want to
show you this okay how hard is it can we
train to be honest it looks pretty hard
okay well let's see oh God that's really
hard to look at
I don't I think it's fine it's a medical
group it's a graphic it's not even
bloody yeah you want some [__]
that's not a doctor to do this yeah well
hold on let's I just want to see I want
to see how how easy okay yeah that looks
pretty gnarly yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I would rather have
this be you know like have highly
trained qualifications for this dude
yeah I'm not saying they shouldn't be
highly trained yeah play the chestnut
song over this instead how about that
that's not said it not me after watching
this Ethan I I don't I don't know
procedures like what the [__] we
literally we are not living in the 14th
century okay we're in 2023 we already
know that this [__] is like super hard
to do
this is honestly that's a lot of that
stuff on there Ethan's like I don't get
it like what's the deal with surgery you
just like cut someone
I mean that's the same like caveman
[__] attitude that people had in like
I was wild to see though yeah it was
crazy yeah I could do that
I could do that
it's just a little sucky sucky yeah if
you practice you get a VR you get a
little eyeball Ethan I'm seeing this
video is actually advertising
cataractcoach.com maybe this is
so so um
optometrists are like uh like get that
off screen a lot of the division uh is a
part of like healthcare is usually not
like fully covered by Insurance almost
globally and part of that is because
like it is a very privatized sector and
they maintain low prices on some of the
things uh I think like LASIK in general
like Lasik eye surgery is one that like
Libertarians always talk about is it
laser guy surgery let me I think I think
it's a lot of private companies that do
the Lasix yeah so like they're always
they always use that as like uh well
look how easy it is to do Lasik eye
surgery like and that's because it's
deregulated and I'm like nope [__] it
get let the government pay for it make
sure that the people doing it are you
know make sure
because you got to go to you got to go
to the doc to become a doctor it's like
eight 12 years something like that right
of school on top of your bachelors
so let's say this
eyeball sucking school one year all
about eyeball sucking they'll be more
trained than a doctor you think doctors
do one year on eyeball sucking hell no
one year I don't know that I don't know
the process but I'm sure that you need
to learn everything about like the brain
and human anatomy before you can do
eyeball sucking
you're ultimately going to come around
to my argument which is that like you
need in order to become a doctor you
definitely need
training and you definitely need a [__]
load of knowledge and it's not about
like deregulating uh that aspect the
regulating the training aspect it's more
so about uh making it so that more
doctors can exist by
depleting the the financial component I
mean making it easier for people to
become doctors in general Yeah Tim Poole
was advocating for Tim pool is actually
with us this is a a Moment of clarity
for our country Mr Beast is galvanizing
everybody to make cataract surgery
accessible this year Hassan biker wait
having seen that video would you let
Ethan suck your eyeball it's still 22
says yes no they're still yeah I did a
new poll a post video to see what the
change is I guarantee
somebody came from eyeball sucking
school after one year and they sat here
they'd be they'd have all the facts bro
and you'll be with 99
suck me Daddy
anyway whatever somebody uh uh a uh fan
just left a message I'm studying
Optometry and the space you're working
with in a cataract surgery is like one
tenth of a millimeter but I think Ethan
could do it there it is maybe the fans
you're not helping Jay
yeah
my mind Ethan's got it okay yeah yeah
y'all are freaks they're smaller the
space the less work yeah okay it's a
good thing it's a good thing yeah why do
we need med school bro people are
[__] crazy like hell med school is
good med school is good it's just so
it's it's bankrupt dude it's defunct
it's just silly you don't need that kind
of training didn't say that
[Music]
you watch this video go oh how how cute
and how nice I watched the video and I'm
filled with rage
along with you that we shut off access
to a 10 minute procedure because we pay
walled it and decided that like some
people just simply can't get it
it is so insanely frustrating that it
like it's up to like people who are two
people where's Tim talking about it I
just heard us on say all that uh in two
seconds he's literally in the room with
me dexterra says twitch streamer has
Sonic's priest
uncanny ability to pause things right
before it gets to the relevance he's not
ragging on Mr Beast oh dexterra says
twitch streamer her son explained why
he's filled with rage from watching Mr
BEAST's newest video where he cures a
thousand people's blindness
he's right why is it up to one YouTube
guy to make content off of this which
will generate money
to to do this mind-blowing to me he's
right another man he doesn't even fully
go off the rails in my opinion like he
just he just look I'll just give you the
short and sweet of it I covered this
yesterday as well he's actually mad
about my coverage of it because like one
of my [__] fan channels Hassani
Productions posted it like you know Tim
Poole calls out Hassan [__] or whatever
when like he was agreeing with me and
you know [__] awesome production is
doing click bait again getting me in
trouble but
um he basically says the government is
spending a hundred billion dollars in
Ukraine the government is giving
millions of dollars to do like uh you
know uh gender education in Pakistan or
whatever why the [__] are they spending
that money on that they should just be
spending the money here on Healthcare
which I agree okay I agree but I was
making of making fun of Tim Poole saying
like yeah the [__] the the the gender
thing is true okay the foreign the state
department does [__] like that
specifically for PR because they want
the Liberals in in America to be like oh
yeah uh you know our military machine
isn't just about uh endless Bloodshed
and and extracting natural resources
from the third world by force it's
actually about teaching people in
Pakistani madrases about they them
non-binary people like it's not that's
just a [__] that's literally a blip
on the radar it's just I love that's
like that it's 10 million dollars
nothing like that that's of the national
budget and I [__] doubt that that
actually ends up going to a program like
that dude if you if you express that as
like a percentage of the national budget
it'll look like safe one safe Moon's
value
you know what I mean yeah it's nothing
any like misunderstood and he got mad he
was like even when I'm defending Hassan
like why is he [__] attacking me and
I was like bro it's a [__] fan
account like good research there Tim
yeah he said you don't do your team he
says I didn't do my research but I
actually did I'm like I didn't
I didn't say that the government is not
actually you know spending money on on
teaching people in Pakistan about being
non-binary or whatever I I know that
there is a blip on the there's the
overall budget part of the funding
agreement for Ukraine is they have to
put kitty litter boxes in public
bathrooms for all the yeah the cat girls
to use we we are not we're we're not in
Ukraine because we want emancipation for
Ukrainian people we're in Ukraine
because we needed to reappropriate the
budgets from Afghanistan to
like another Avenue and this was perfect
true king
let's talk about let's move on to
Stephen Crowder being a bisexual god
king let's do it now Crowder of course
who's gotten into controversy uh with
Ben Shapiro of all people and all the
folks down at the daily wire now this is
significant because I don't think gay
people are allowed to join or bisexual
people allowed to join the daily wire so
this could affect their negotiating
status there
um right after we got off the air last
week
somebody this four-year-old clip of him
flew totally under the radar
I sent this to you immediately and you
were shocked by it too I don't know how
any of us didn't see this until now
but this is Stephen Crowder
basically
in a very vulnerable moment
admitting that he's been with men
I believe maybe not necessarily been
with okay well what does he mean at
least maybe just attraction or like just
considered it because that's what he
experiences every day the man's
attracted to the men
but he acted on it that's with the
bisexual phase he's referring to maybe
watch the video and we'll make our we'll
make up sometimes you have to make hard
decisions more it's from an episode
called something about fear he's having
like a really open this is a heartfelt
yeah 14-minute video by Stephen Crowder
from four years prior I believe if not
maybe a little bit older than that was
is this from 24 20 or is it is four
years ago where he has like he talks
about his biggest fears he talks about
all of this like emotional stuff and in
between that this got lost in the weeds
I guess he has a is a heartfelt moment
where he's talking about you know let's
just just play the video let's let's
hear what he what he's talking about
yeah it's called close or Crowder close
closes defeating fear so this is a very
serious video and now let's take a look
and sometimes you think you have to make
hard decisions and it's just wrong I'm
afraid of that
uh I'm afraid of
I'm afraid frankly I used to have a bad
temper I'm afraid of it coming back I'm
afraid of this man has a gun on his desk
talking about how he has a bad temper
chill bro what do you mean brother he's
I'm on the edge you know he knows how to
handle that he's got proper proper
training I've got an issue with anger
and I'm always within one foot of a gun
Mr Hyde rearing is ugly bisexual head
that was a short face you [__] paused
it right I'm afraid God damn it please
yeah and and Zach you played a sound
bite right over it too what are you guys
doing it
I'm afraid of it coming back I'm afraid
of Mr Hyde rearing is bisexual head that
was a that was a short phase
um no I'm afraid afraid of afraid of
getting angry was it that's so
interesting yeah
he said he's afraid of Mr Hyde rearing
his bisexual head ugly bisexual ugly
bisexual head
um it was just a short phase in college
which I I think I'm interpreting that as
he had some kind of sexual interaction
with the man
as he says it was a short face or or
attraction which is valid you know
here's the thing uh we know for a fact
that he was an abstinence only guy
until marriage he like was very proud of
that fact
um he's advocated for it numerous times
and uh we know that he's coming from a
repressed family
there's rainbows in chat for Crowder by
the way I appreciate you all supporting
him a couple things to obviously make
note of not uh not every single uh there
is
there is a significantly larger amount
of straight people that just hate gay
people
then there are repressed homosexuals
okay so that's number sometimes you have
them before people [__] jump down
Ethan and I's literally just said he's
bisexual like
um so that's number one like whenever
you see whenever you see someone who's
like you know homophobic that doesn't
immediately imply that they themselves
are gay right we're not blaming
homophobia on gay people
um but every gay person and you know
everyone that understands Stephen
Crowder is a library of content will
tell you that he's zesty as [__] okay my
man's fruity I'm just gonna say it do
you understand
there's a lot going on there's a lot
dude he cross-dresses way too much and
I'm saying this is a guy who's done like
Dragon cross dress like he cross-dresses
as more than George Santos right a gay
man who openly has now admitted to
watching uh RuPaul's Drag Race you know
what we need to call his show prouder
with Crowder yeah if he was a little bit
prouder if he was a little bit prouder
maybe he wouldn't be so [__] angry
all the time and you know what
yeah I don't think he's gonna cross the
dress too much I think he's just he's
like on a dime's notice he's that man is
ready to put on a dress and express
himself proudly there is not there was a
point in time before like Republicans
decided that like doing drag meant that
you're like satanic pedophile or
whatever there was a point in time
before like you know drag is a long
culture long history it's a it's a big
part of theater in general
um and Stephen Crowder used to do it
literally for anything and everything
not just like women's issues not just to
like make fun of trans people or
whatever but he would do drag for like
random [__] like uh like Planet Fitness
you know what I mean like
yeah yeah I'm gonna wear a dress like
dude you're doing a doing a video on
tort reform why the [__] are you in a
dress yeah you know what I mean what the
[__] going on I love those videos of
him like it just it felt like it was
genuine like he was you know doing the
thing where he's like well of course
what's interesting about this is that he
is homophobic and he has garnered an
extremely homophobic audience
um and what's really interesting
actually I pulled up a screenshot of the
live chat I don't know if you saw it but
his fans when he said that in the live
chat they're like shame on you Crowder
did he just say he's bisexual
it was just the comment section
I just said you can be straight and do
drag like you know sad face or whatever
it's like yeah I'm straight and I just
said I I've done dread like that's not
what I'm saying at all don't
misunderstand me he's that the man wants
to
Express himself and that's the only way
he can oh this is straight from the
comments
uh yeah um I have an extension that
allows you to search comments so I just
uh I just put Buy in there bro and uh
his fans were
raising eyebrows three years ago this
man said proud of you for coming out
yeah I mean he
yeah he he
it's not a phase I don't think you know
what I mean I don't think he was just
like questioning I think he's just like
repressing it
a lot of uh here I'll give you an
example of someone who I don't think is
gay at all that hates all Queer people
Matt [__] Walsh like you won't hear
me say that dude yeah no he's just he's
just he's just a bigger yeah he's just
an awful [__] bigoted piece of [__]
uh and that that shit's you know that's
just internally in him not not because
like he's internalizing it or anything
he's just you know he feels it in his
heart as a straight person this is some
of the comments on that video just to
give you an idea of why he's repressing
this and the kind of you know audience
he's built shame on crowder for being
bisexual he said he's bisexual Crowders
disgusting did you say you had a
bisexual phase is that a joke glad the
Crowder came out proud of you
uh that one I like does Crowder admit
that he has a bisexual phase your
bisexual hide uh even Crowder himself
has said in the past that like if you
claim you're bisexual as a guy you're
gay LOL which I think he now has deleted
this well and now because you I think we
know what who he's talking about you
know what I mean yeah which by the way
is not true you know by visibility by
Pride okay uh you know the only time we
do buy invisibility is when we're
talking about Christian Cinema uh all
other times by visibility all day
um it's just you know he he might be bi
he might be gay
but uh and we love that for him and I
encourage you Stephen and I welcome you
to join us for a Pride menu
and maybe that's a good way to get his
pose wet because I think as Jordan
Peterson aptly pointed out pride month
is way too [__] long so if we can get
him into a pride minute maybe that's a
good way to wet his toes and uh
see that the water is nice and warm over
here but since we've been talking about
this clip Crowder has disappeared from
the internet
yeah he hasn't posted a lot he hasn't
posted anything Candace Owens kind of
came after him and said like y'all
should pray for him bless his heart yeah
I mean that sort of thing and yeah I
haven't really seen a lot of activity
from Stephen Crowder since then I I
actually spent a decent amount of time
last night kind of trying to find out
what's going on with this Channel and I
think what it is is you know he got
dropped by The Blaze and he got dropped
whatever
[Music]
he was way more tight-lipped about that
than he was with the daily wire stuff he
seemed to not want to get into the Weeds
on it but ever since then all the
content that he's really posted was this
whole war with daily wire
um if you go to his channel those are
the only video recent videos at all and
since that last one where he you know
played the secret recording that he made
that's the last thing that's been posted
to his YouTube channel at all dude um so
I don't know it's possible they're just
on vacation or something I don't know if
you want to read into that too much
nobody wants to work anymore man yeah
she's [__] lazy quiet quitting dude
so true what the [__] is this [__]
yep you show up at work yeah exactly
that's how we feel but yeah the last
thing was that uh candy
was the threatening to expose his we're
inferring homosexuality so he is hiding
he's in hiding right now now here's the
thing come over to us we accept you for
who you are bro he's even been silent on
Twitter like I looked through his likes
he's liked one or two posts
um but that's about it he hasn't really
tweeted
have any conservatives reacted to this
clip like any of his fans like I'm
really curious what they'll think about
this I mean a lot of the like alt-right
yeah people are like ragging on him you
know for this yeah of course yeah it's
all like it's all like uh in the far
right freaks that have like been making
fun of him for years about this uh I
guess okay that's why like a lot of the
people that pull data from this or
anything resembling like something that
might look like Steven Crowder is like
admitting or acknowledging being gay or
whatever is always like from the old
Benjamin sub or something like that
guy's a [__] major piece of [__] [__]
that guy wait here how about this one in
the closet with Crowder
that's from chat don't blame me okay
no Crowder with Crowders better Crowder
was Crowder look at that actually yeah I
mean it's a better play off of his real
title well there it is Crowder you have
two choices to make you can go back to
the alt-right freaks who hate you or you
can come to me and Hassan with open arms
to accept you for who you are I mean
I'll accept them for who he is but he's
still a [__] piece of [__] you know
like he's ready to change though man you
don't even have to think about it dude
you know he's got a long way yeah no
there's a Redemption for that to happen
yeah of course there's a Redemption for
everyone but I'm just saying there is
what about Bill Cosby
even for
I think yeah even even yeah I think even
I've said this before I've built what's
Bill Clinton's Redemption I'm a firm
believer in Rehabilitation I think like
Bill Cosby is unique because he's like
so old
um and and so uh grounded within his
like
and he barely was OJ Simpson
I think every single person
uh with some exceptions okay good every
single person with some exceptions
can and uh can be rehabilitated and they
our focus should always be on
Rehabilitation 100 in reintegration into
society is this real
he's doing a stand-up yeah I guess
Louisville
hello she's out there he's working I
guess he's doing things I guess the show
is just maybe on extended Hiatus because
of all the god dramas for the record I
just want to point out one more thing
about the with the Redemption or
Rehabilitation argument the reason why I
said they're a notable exceptions is
because like there are still things that
we do not have a good grasp on
especially with respect to like
anti-social personality disorder or like
crimes caused by that specifically
pedophilia sexual uh sexually violent
crimes and like serial killers and
whatnot but with those notable
exceptions which may change in the
future we may figure out I mean we
already figured brain is huddle the
bottom me bro but that's like no it
doesn't you know you can't do that
that's oh okay insane I wasn't sure yeah
um but but ultimately a lot of crime is
like the overwhelming majority of crime
is a product of our material conditions
that we're subjected to and therefore
obviously I will always Advocate to fix
the underlying reasons as to why crime
manifests rather than uh focus on you
know punishing criminals harder because
Woody Allen if punishing criminal is
harder what Woody Allen yeah look a lot
of times you're you're pointing to
people who have never faced
accountability and accountability and
and also like serving time is still a
fundamental plays a fundamental role in
in Rehabilitation so of course when you
talk about people like Bill Cosby or
Woody Allen or or uh Roman Polanski and
whatnot like these are people who either
faced very little consequences for their
actions uh and and never even offered
restitution for the victims or whatever
even acknowledged their crimes
um
and and they basically got away with it
which is
the reason why like they're not the best
example
to use well we love we love
Rehabilitation here don't we folks uh we
love to redeem in fact
some some have called me Jesus Christ
for that reason and I accept it without
uh any pushback okay let's talk about it
and you came before me you Lord and said
Jesus I have [__] 20 children oh my
God and I said to you blessed be my son
I shall redeem you
I shall castrate you
castration is that part of redemption no
because Harvey Weinstein's dick was like
horrifically scarred from gangrene and
yet he's still successfully raped you
know
like almost 100 women because that's
what people don't understand chemical
castration or castration in general is
not an adequate punishment because like
rape is not about sexual gratification
rape can give you sexual gratification
but it's about power it's about
exercising power over someone who cannot
consent so therefore you can still do
digital penetration therefore you can
still violate someone's uh bodily
autonomy in different ways so lobotomy
is kind of the only option I'm seeing
for them
but even then then you come then you
arrive at the same concept as the death
penalty which is right like what if you
are lobotomizing someone who is innocent
right like that but I like I like
lobotomy because it's like death
sentence light
I am not an advocate for lobotomy we can
put it we can put the piece of the brain
hold on Kennedy's dude I have an idea
we'll put the little piece of their
brain on ice and if we find out they're
innocent we'll just put it back where we
found it
thought I don't know if it works that
way all right let's move on thank you
we're getting now to the presidential
primaries of between Trump and distincty
Rhonda stinky is heating up and we are
here for it Trump is already kicking off
his re-election campaign and bringing
the heat to DeSantis let's see what he
has to say
I've been governor and go Wesley for me
and that's okay and uh number one he
wouldn't have gotten the nomination
and number two he wouldn't have beaten
uh his Democrat opponent so then when I
hear he might run you know I consider
that very disloyal but it's not about
loyalty but to me it is it's always
about loyalty but for a lot of people
are you surprised to see him he's a mob
I love how mobster Trump is it's awesome
yeah he's badass
um Rhonda stinky has nothing on him okay
I'll just say it after seeing his face
after seeing him at the diamond funeral
like I was like my man
he needs to come back and do more of
that [__] uh straight up as far as like
Rhonda stinky when he talks about
DeSantis and how like he almost lost to
Andrew Gillum it's true Andrew Gillum
was like the up-and-comer in the
Democratic party uh propped up by Obama
himself young uh black man who then uh
turned out to be a fan of doing meth
with uh gay prostitutes at the fountain
blue they all are
the perfect candidate for Florida right
just a man of the people and also
objectively
still more ethical than whatever the
[__] uh Voldemort did before Rhonda said
like human trafficking immigrants well
Rhonda said he's human trafficking
because I was talking about Rick Scott
who uh you know did Medicare fraud so we
love that but anyway DeSantis is
actually taking the bait now and
responding to Trump so things are
heating up my friends this is what I'm
living for
um I roll out of bed I have people
attacking me from all angles it's been
happening for many many years and if you
look at the good thing about it though
is like if you take a crisis situation
like covid you know the good thing about
it is when you're an elected executive
you have to make all kinds of decisions
you got to steer that ship and the good
thing is is that the people are able to
render a judgment on that whether they
re-elect you or not and I'm happy to say
you know in my case not only did we win
re-election we won with the highest
percentage of the vote that any republ
book and governor candidate has in the
history he just [__] torched him with
that is Ron DeSantis uh has he spoken
out about the election being uh fixed
uh well I mean he did the election uh he
did the the cops that like went into
people's uh houses
and stuff
um he has talked about it a little bit
because when he was like riding for
Trump I just find it funny because he's
like oh yeah I won by the biggest margin
ever
well I was like the vote works there
here's the thing about election fraud
and this is a point that I made many
times over and I think I need to make it
again
it's not just Trump that has talked
about election fraud he's not the first
and he will certainly not be the last
election or not election fraud voter
fraud is a vehicle is a propaganda piece
that the Republican party has used
historically to undermine the Integrity
of Elections so they can continue
justifying voter suppression like
closing polls uh closing places uh where
there are you know closing polling
stations in poorer neighborhoods black
and brown communities specifically and
also implementing like a signature
verification processes or voter ID laws
that also again disproportionately stop
poorer people from going out to vote
making sure that voting is happening on
a work day in the middle of the [__]
day uh you know these are these are all
many different ways in which those in
positions of power whether it be
democrat or republican have tried to
actively stop the Working Poor from
going out and participating in their
civic duty so they they will continue to
lie about it it's not just about Trump
it's not the big lie that Trump promoted
I think the Liberals kind of fail when
they when they make this a trump thing
but yeah well we don't have to worry
about that because this new culture war
is gas stoves my friend which ironic
because Florida majority electric stoves
Florida does not have the same kind of
gas infrastructure that California has
the 68 of the country uses electric
stoves and the overwhelming majority of
Florida already use electric stoves they
do not use gas stoves he's just straight
up doing this specifically because it's
a cultural talking point it's so [__]
stupid it's so insane how they construct
these things like they they've created
this fiction I guess there was some
research that showed that having gas
stoves in your house can make the air
really unhealthy
yeah and especially for kids and I don't
know why like why are they just figuring
that out like you have an open flame in
your house
you're burning gas in your house wow
from what I was reading it's long been
suspected but it was just there was a a
large study that was just came out
recently and it was specifically about
um it being behind a lot of childhood
asthma that is very interesting yeah
yeah there's a lot of gases like not
captured adequately right
um well so so anyway they're they've
created this fiction that now Liberals
are coming for their stoves and uh as
silly as that sounds that really is what
they're saying and then we just added
because I think it needs to be done uh
no tax permanently on gas stoves they
want your gas stove and we're not going
to let that happen and we're not even a
state the way Florida was built a lot of
this wasn't even connected the gas lines
he's acknowledging it he's acknowledging
it yo I just looked it up it's even
crazier than you said Hassan no 68 of
the entire country overwhelming majority
of Florida though 92 electric stoves
wait it's Florida it's just in
California where we have gas California
and other like uh older I guess like
older cities that had gas lights
uh that had a pre-built infrastructure
for gas basically kept using gas stoves
and most other uh more recent
developments more recent like uh City
developments you just use electric wait
how do they Heat their AC and [__]
electric electric yeah what do you mean
AC is already electric what are you
talking about no like isn't our Central
AC like gas powered no yes it is AC it
burns gas in California yes yeah your
water heater could either be electric or
gas
um that's okay so the AC shouts out to
to uh I think it's climate town right
they did a really really good video on
this
um I highly recommend you guys check
them out uh climate Town talked about
this disparity a long time ago as a
matter of fact before this culture War
even heated up gas stoves are the entry
point
into using uh natural gas as a as a
heating substitute so like when when
asked uh when you ask random people like
if their home is
if their home is powered by gas or
electric they have no idea but the only
place where they do have a preference or
or the only place where they do actually
think about this is gas stoves versus
electric stoves now part of that is
because electric stoves early on were
not as powerful as gas stoves it I think
takes like four extra minutes to boil
water on an electric stove in comparison
to a gas stove which is why the oil and
gas industry dumped a lot of money into
marketing for many many years
the idea
that uh the the the colloquialism
cooking with gas which is something that
I use all the time I'm sure you've used
it before that was literally a marketing
technique by the oil and gas industry
how [__] crazy is that that it's been
a well it's played such a fundamental
role like that that marketing technique
has made its way into our language
without us even recognizing it and it
plays a small but still significant role
in like people thinking that gas stoves
are better than electric and that's the
only thing that uh that consumers have a
preference on but of course the the uh
the the oil and gas industry
specifically want to maintain their
profit margins and they don't want to
change the infrastructure because if the
infrastructure is changed to focus on
electricity then all of a sudden they're
gonna they're gonna lose a lot of
Revenue I thought the gas was fine I
didn't think it was a big deal like the
natural gas issue I thought it
was actually a cleaner alternative it
burns pretty clean we have a ton of it
here in California it's not that
expensive because there's so much of it
so I thought that it was actually like a
relatively good thing we had going but
am I wrong should I be going electric on
my stoves
um induction stoves are better than
electric
um from what I understand they're
they're actually literally better than
gas as well well what's better mean
better isn't like faster heat up faster
the only difference you need like a
specific induction uh walk for example
like you can't use the same kinds of
yeah uh okay interesting well
um I am coming for their stoves uh you
hear me
but it's yeah it's because 93 of the
people in Florida are not even using gas
it's such a stupid ass [__] virtue
signal I'm looking at this yeah I'm
looking at the study
and I think it actually is the highest
of any state yeah I love it it's
literally that it's so easy for them to
come out and be like listen I'm making
the great sacrifice we're not taxing the
five gas stoves we've sold in the state
yeah no it's just culture warship which
is ironic though because like
a lot of places
a lot of places where conservatives live
actually are like Florida where the
majority of uh majority of places use
electric which is why it's like this
doesn't even impact them well I'm just
advocating for like liberals to continue
using gas I guess we're we're redoing
our kitchen at my house and I was
adamant about getting gas stoves they've
tried to get me on electric but you're
[__] dupe dogs I like cooking with
gas baby that's but but see that's the
point like you know what was my concern
what I was like I'm gonna get these
electric burners and in five to ten
years these things are going to be
[__] like broken as [__] because you
know with like Tech and all that [__]
well I mean your gas stove can break too
and especially when you're guessing gas
stove forever no they definitely break I
have a guest over my house right there
and it's a [__] yeah it's a melee one
too and it's still [__] broken it
breaks all the goddamn time everything
breaks it's just everything is made to
break but
um yeah there is no I I don't I don't
think the gas those are particularly
better Nicole says less dangerous
because if gas stoves break you can
[__] burn your house out of electric
slow brakes I don't think you have yeah
that's always been what's so interesting
to me about in California in particular
having so much gas infrastructure and
everything is that we get [__]
earthquakes here and when that happens
that's what starts like giant fires all
over the place I remember I remember my
family had uh uh have like an emergency
turn off in the 94 uh Northridge
Earthquake because it broke the gas line
doesn't everybody have an emergency turn
off or is that a revelation after the
North Ridge earthquake I was so young
that I don't know like I don't remember
that being like a really scary thing
that our family went through after that
first thing yeah I know that like our
house has an earthquake detector like an
automatic I'll close it ours did not
yeah I guess maybe that's a new thing
because since then I think but yeah I
don't know this uh Nicole says that in
uh conduction is expensive and requires
special cookware
but should I switch
should I go uh
I mean there the IRA actually has a a
financial incentive built into it I'm
pretty sure you can get like
you get uh subsidized really yeah we're
making a switch to uh an electric stove
yeah I already bought it I think I might
be [__] on that one there aren't they
mandating new buildings now in
California like I'm not sure I wouldn't
be surprised at least I think it's like
because I I know there was like a
controversy over it because a lot of um
restaurants you know Cooks have their
preferences and they're much more
serious and and dedicated to one side or
the other even a lot of them no but even
a lot of [__] Cooks have been paid
for by really yes so there was a
marketing campaign on Instagram from
like Instagram chefs they specifically
looked at like different demographics on
who is more likely to be duped by this I
guess and they found out that like young
Latinos like up and coming uh Latinos
were were it was way more effective so
they went after like uh Latino uh chefs
on Instagram so uh climate Town details
this perfectly like I said highly
recommend the channel highly recommend
that video they're brilliant
um
but uh they they they had like young
Latino chefs they were like I prefer
cooking with gas over electric because
it's much better like it's more
authentic don't more chefs prefer gas
though that's real there are a lot of
chefs who still prefer gas I think they
they like it old school first of all no
one is a [__] real Chef when we're
talking about this so they don't they
don't need the intricacies a lot of
chefs who now also prefer uh induction
so right um so yeah I'm late on this one
electric stoves did used to suck like
maybe they were inferior but I think I
think they've been yeah yeah I agree
with that I guess I'm uh late to this
convo so here she is I I am a chef I
prefer gas for controllability induction
is good but gets too hot too fast
sometimes and but uh pole pan off
induction stove and the stove will be
cold electric stays hot for too long
gas forever bro you do not play your
[__] fingers on my gas stove I mean I
I'm a dirty little gas stove user you
know what I mean but I am also a normal
human being who has no preference or one
over the other and I don't think it will
like genuinely impact my life also as a
homeowner we're in a different uh
situation than everyone else most people
don't make these decisions their
landlord makes these things
you know what I mean I see lots of
people riding for induction yeah I do
like that's really cool too I like that
when you take the pan off it's cold and
I mean with someone with kids that's
like right you know I don't that's true
the stove is a scary thing so that's
pretty cool actually but the only the
purchase has been made the only thing
that the gas stove has over electric
which is why you will never pry it from
my cold dead hands is that you can light
your cigarettes on it boy no you can you
toss the tortilla on that bad boy
Preppers prefer gas that's just given
yeah how you got how old the apocalypse
how are you going to use induction then
yeah they also prefer like Iraqi dinar
and [__] so I don't think they're making
a lot of I don't think they're making a
lot of sense I probably prefer propane
right because what's propane
gasoline my brother yeehaw
get some glazies on the open flight
that good one man it don't take out
another one man tell you what man no
damn gas
I was about to say yeah it is new
episode yeah yeah greatest Slice of Life
anime of all time absolutely incredible
[__] I love that show I hope it's not
ruined well is it my judge also still is
a performer though he's not just coming
back yeah yeah it's like all the all the
original voice actors too yep that's
great that's interesting yeah but back
to uh the stinky here let's finish this
but it's just the principle of you know
this is ridiculous that they and they do
want to go oh God damn it after it they
got blow back so they kind of had to
back off they want to go
so we're saying you know we want you to
be able to buy those uh uh free to the
five people we want you to he's such a
[__]
it's so transparent that they are like
that he's just trying to create a
problem where no such problem exists
specifically for like the culture War
narrative but it's funny it's funny that
they're talking about this okay it's
funny that they're talking about this
instead of like uh talking about you
know Joe Brandon's documents right like
which to me immediately points to the
reality the Grim reality of the Joe
Biden document drama did not work at all
CNN's been talking about that [__] way
more than Fox News I think all the sales
got sucked out of the document
controversy because it was like you're
finding out now that basically every
president is just incompetent and has
top secret documents laying around but
also like they're coll they're they're
working with the authorities like that
was the main difference between Trump
and what everyone else would be lost on
Fox News viewers but apparently they
don't care yeah they just don't give a
[__] about document mishandling
um so this is all based on this New York
Times headline
gas gas stoves are tied to health
concerns here's how to lower your risk
this this is um
the existential threat that uh Ron
DeSantis is worried about study
published last year found that families
who use gas stoves and homes with poor
ventilation or without range hoods can
blow past the National Standard for safe
hourly outdoor exposure to nitrogen
oxides within just a few minutes
so it makes our child it and it has a
likelihood to increase childhood asthma
the likelihood of childhood asthma
occurring it is all good yes one right
to expose our children to toxic fumes
it's got Diamond guess what
what's that we're making our children's
lungs stronger that's right man
I believe we need to go back to asbestos
as well and also let chips in the paint
of our children's toys that made our
children more dangerous I tell you what
boy
I that's why I told my wife to drink
when she's pregnant because that's our
child and I we do what we want here I
says we gonna drink and we gonna use gas
and with no with the hood off boy
because this is America it's like
circumcision you know what I mean your
your Pappy had it so you need to have it
too do you understand me it's just like
that I have fetal alcohol syndrome and
so should my child so we continue the
goddamn we continue the goddamn Bridge
my baby looked like a goddamn hammerhead
shark okay amen
the feet of alcohol syndrome is a
trademark of our family genetics how
else are we going to continue uh you
know
you know breeding conservative
hydrations okay without them getting
poisoned that's right
actually early polls have uh tightening
between Trump and DeSantis but one thing
I did want to help Trump out with
is that his nicknames for Ron have been
incredibly weak so far so Ron Des
sanctimonious was just a disaster too
much too much too mouthy well we we put
together a lot of suggestions actually
we have a lot of suggestions for Trump
I like Rhonda stinky that's the one you
use
I'll rattle off a few
Ron Deez Nuts
no Ron this functional
deep State DeSantis I like that that's a
good one that's power alliteration is
always good deep State descent he's
working with the Deep State you got to
say it in the Trump boys yeah
that one actually could actually I feel
like that one could hit him hard deep
yeah DeSantis around depression so uh
wrong DeSantis is one that I've also
come up with as well I see this on the
list uh wait what you just said his name
wrong wrong
he's always wrong another one is Rhonda
so I I uh wrong another thing that
another Avenue that Trump can hit Rhonda
santhisan and this goes to the whole
like the boot Saga remember when he was
wearing the boots and then they like and
then they memed it into like wearing
like these sexy ass thigh highs you know
Silly boots run silly boots run all
right looking at this picture I haven't
seen in a minute this is a fashion
Holocaust yeah you could you could like
hit the angle of like Randa he wants to
be a woman he's gay you know that sort
of thing that would definitely appeal to
his audience like he's so feminine Randa
I call him little Ronda
how about um uh Ron let's see wrong
distances when you said Rhonda deceiver
Ron Ron desquintis because he Squints
Rhonda squinters I don't know that
doesn't hit like I mean he does have you
ever seen his eyes folks he doesn't have
eyes he doesn't have eyes he's a reptile
my eyes so closed all the time
Ron the [__] Ron disgusting Ron the
Satan Rhonda Satanist yeah
uh
Ron dousey
like a woman Ron declining poll numbers
Ron demonic
Ron disgusting oh there's a good one in
here that I hadn't thought about Rhonda
Rhino yeah oh I like that he's a rhino
folks yeah
Rhonda Single Ladies what
uh Ron desise Queen wow
Ron deportum
I think that's a that probably that's
himself yeah he's not trying to he's not
trying to glaze him Ron descended
stomach because he's fat some of these
are so bad Ron deteriorate no wrong
Theft Auto San Andreas the San Andreas
dude yeah yeah Ron dinaris Rhonda Norris
actually of all these ones folks if I'm
being serious for a moment here please I
was never not serious this is a very
serious issue
if Trump if Trump wants to defeat Ron in
the Republican primaries deep State Ron
is the best one deep State Ron that one
would destroy him I think little Rhonda
he's so little he's like a woman that
one is good little Rhonda I don't know
like I know that his voters don't care
but that one alienates some people deep
State DeSantis is like speaks
I know but like you have to like
you have to find a reason why he's like
Pro deep State you know what I mean and
there isn't much because he does like he
follows the Trump method really closely
so like he's also portrayed himself as
like Auntie deep State yeah if you just
lie trouble just makes [__] up yeah
um
I mean this is a careful one this this
is a delicate matter uh and well if
we've gone over these you know sure as
hell Trump's gone all over all over
these no I think he's like he thinks
he's so good like he doesn't need to but
he does like you're not this is
important this is going to be really
important Trump like with the nft [__]
like he is not as popping as he once was
Oh wrong ah
[Music]
you can also like do some like ethnic uh
hatred there you'll be like he's Italian
folks he's stinky he's not showering you
know how Italians are or something like
that you know I lived in New York I know
how Italians are but leave me folks
believe me folks like that kind of thing
you know
because a lot of his a lot of his
audience like
a lot of his fans like they one even if
he shits on them directly they love that
they're like yeah we are we are Stinky
you're right you know and also uh if
you're if you're in the South and you're
like not Italian you know what I mean if
you're like uh Anglo-Saxon uh then you
you could maybe get into that like old
anti-anti-catholic sentiment wrong
dementia old school although Trump's way
older so that's not gonna really work
yeah well there it is Trump if you are
watching and I I know probably at least
one of your dumbass Sons is
uh maybe they can pass a couple of those
suggestions on to you for our enjoyment
Junior's a long time fan of this show
yeah well on our first this is true he's
been a he's been a first day he's a real
leftover you have that he's not a
bandwagon fan he's been on the floor
with all of that leftovers leftovers
talk to you soon I wish you well
all right well that's about all we've
got we covered everything eh that's it
God damn look at that we did it another
Banger episode I mean there's the Paul
Pelosi Attack video but it's just
disturbing I didn't feel like watching
it oh I've already yeah you probably
covered that a lot I've covered it
extensively and made a lot of jokes it's
absolutely insane how yeah you know what
gay sex is punished in this country
still there's a video of this man
breaking into the house with a hammer
yeah
striking him with a hammer when the
police show up and people go why wasn't
he wearing pants they were obviously I
mean I'm sorry uh it's it's called daddy
Dom role play they're deep enrolled and
they're doing it no the most offensive
part about it is that like listen
why the [__] are do you think that if
Paul Pelosi is a gay man okay you think
he's gonna [__] David to Pappy or get
[__] by David to Papi he's in San
Francisco there's like blood boys
premium cars yeah you can get the best
kind of [__] on the market yeah [__]
David that's the single best
um I hadn't thought explanation I've
heard it's insane it's insane absolutely
you can't simultaneously say these guys
have like untapped uh you know baby
reserves that they get adrenochrome from
and then simultaneously be like but the
only the only uh you know gay prostitute
he could get was David the Papi maybe
David's uh hung like a [__] hog like
a horse bro it doesn't matter where's
your daddy maybe he's a side maybe um
San Francisco he's got plenty of them
maybe maybe uh San Francisco what's his
name
the Papi no the Paul Pelosi maybe he's a
size queen
it doesn't matter he could find like uh
I think so he could find someone with a
way bigger [__] you think so yeah with
with uh you know who's way sexier than
some [__] basement dwelling grouper
like David de Pepe
yeah well there it is folks uh it's all
happening this is America
we're covering it all live here from our
gajillion dollar bunker
did you are you watching Last of Us no
not yet I watched the first episode
I heard there's Guy characters in it I
don't want to [__] push that with 10
foot pole the third episode was crazy I
don't want to touch that they're
teaching our children this [__] what the
[__] there's definitely dude kissing in
the third app whoa trigger warning just
to warn y'all dude them lips do touch
let's [__] and I'll tell you what man
that's why them Zombies come out when
those two men kiss yeah that's what God
Said
We Gotta Laugh kissing our homies
released stop doing it you know even
though I think about it right that's
right I think about the Luscious Lips
that's right beard hair touching my
beard
when I'm lonely at night by myself
that's right Stephen Crowder in the
bisexual Mr Hyde phase he had in college
I tell you what man people been
wondering who was that miss that Mr Hyde
phase it was me and my aunt me and crowd
are Embrace at the time want no face for
me boy tell you what
all right bye okay
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]